welcome to the RAF Museum in London
we're here today to unveil the London
element of the wargaming.net supported
Dornier interpretation zone in the
Battle of Burton Hall behind me the
public can get to grips with the
conservation itself take part in
conserving this unique aircraft
since the lift last June near a plane
has been transported to Cosford and
she's now in two hydration tunnels the
fuselage is in one tunnel the wings and
the other one and we're constantly
coating it with a citric acid solution
the intention there is to purge the
aggressive chloride salts on the
structure and make it safe enough for
display
there's a lot of work being done on
recovering metal objects from the sea
but not very much on aluminium aluminium
doesn't normally survive for this long
so they're in conservation typically is
very mild acids so things like vinegar
and lemon juice and carbonic acid all
those stuff that we cook they're natural
they're not very aggressive so basing it
on one of those types of formulations
was where we started
this is very much new science when we're
pioneering a new methodology a new
technology but it's progressing
exceptionally well we've managed to
clean the fuselage exterior so far we're
now focusing on the interior the
fuselage across the wings but so far
we're very very encouraged
my role in the project is to conserve
these smaller artifact components they
come out of the tunnel that get logged
photographed and then they get worked by
team of our team of volunteers
well the dawnia is obviously an original
aeroplane and it's the only dawnie that
we know of anywhere in the world to
restore it back to pristine condition
like the aeroplane you see around you
here there's no point in doing that we
wouldn't have an original little plane
anymore so then versus very much is on
conservation rather than restoration so
the Huracan is a wrecked that was shot
down in 1940 back in Britain the dawnia
will be very much conserved and
displayed as as discovered we're also
now helping them in trying to understand
how to treat the surface once we've
cleaned it so once it's been clean and
stabilized and you've got the artifact
in its metallic state again and stable
I'm just going to put it on display you
want to have some kind of coating on
there so we're looking a little bit at
the different types of coatings or waxes
or polishes that can just help as a
buffer to increase the life tile and
keep it in the right condition
as part of our partnership with
wargaming we've shared the Dornier with
the world there are hundreds of virtual
doilies at locations across the globe
the wargaming community have been taking
photos of these dawnia's and sharing
them by the Dornier website we're really
excited to be able to reach out to new
audiences using this exciting new
technology
as a company were very proud to
obviously be part of the Dornier
projects we've always always had a great
passion for history in wargaming and
education as well and the two really go
hand in hand so it's been absolutely
fantastic to be partners